hey this is pressure Locker points a and
B are opposite corners of a 5x5 grid
Alice starts at Point a and each second
walks one edge right or up each
direction with a 50% chance until Alice
reaches point B at the same time that
Alice has started Bob starts at point B
and he moves one edge left or down each
with a 50% probability until he reaches
point a now I've shown these two paths
one after the other but in actuality
they have been simultaneously Alice and
Bob are randomly walking at the same
time the question is what is the
probability Alice and Bob meet during
the random walk here by meeting I mean
occupy the same point at the same time
what is the same probability for an N by
n grid and what is the limit as n goes
to infinity can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll get started by considering the
possible positions that Alice and Bob
can be after K steps after one step
they're going to be pretty close to
their original starting point they're
not going to be able to cross paths the
same thing goes after two steps three
steps and four steps
but after five steps it's possible that
they could be at the same point at the
same time we can see this algebraically
when Alice is K steps from point A Bob
is also 10 minus K steps from point A so
the only point at which they can meet
happen when K equals 10 minus K which
has a solution for K equals 5 steps so
the only possible point at which they
can meet are 5 steps from either of
their starting points this is along the
main diagonal of this grid we now need
to count the number of ways in which
each of them could reach one of these
meeting points we'll start out with
Alice going from point A in the first
step
Alice can either go up or right now if
she goes up this is the only one way
that she could reach this point that's
directly one step up from point A
similarly there's only one way that she
could reach the point that's directly
right from the starting point what
happens in the second step well from
these points she can either go up or
right again if she had gone up in the
first step she could go up again and
there's only one way that she could be
two points up from point A or she could
have gone two points right from point A
and there's only one way that she could
have gotten to this point but imagine
she had gone right first she could go up
and reach this point that's diagonal
point A or if she had gone up she could
have done gone right and reached the
same point they're two different paths
to reach this point now what happens in
the next step
we can continue this imagine Alice goes
up or right here well there's only one
way she could have gotten here here she
could have gone to this one point and
gone right or she could have gone to the
past were there two paths and then gone
up so this will be 1 plus 2 which equals
three different ways she could have
gotten to this point similarly when we
look at the next point we add two and
one to get three possible paths to get
to this point here we only have one path
is if she had gone right three times so
there's a pattern here we can add up the
numbers from the adjacent edges to get
the number of ways to get to the new
point this is going to look very much
like Pascal's triangle another way of
looking at this is that a step the paths
are described by the binomial expansion
of the quantity u plus R to the power of
K so if we continue this we can count
the number of paths to each different
point so I'm going to start filling in
the numbers and get the number of ways
that Alice could get to these common
meeting points so now let's just focus
on these numbers on the diagonal by
symmetry the pattern is going to be
exactly the same for Bob starting from
point B so we're going to end up with
exactly the same number of ways that Bob
could reach these meeting points and his
paths would be described by similar
binomial expansion of the quantity D
plus L to the power of K where D is down
and L is left so now we can figure out
the probability for a given a common
point there are X ways for each person
to get to that point so the total number
of ways that both of them could be there
would be x times X which equals x
squared furthermore we need to know how
many different ways there are for them
to meet
at all so at each step each Walker has
two different choices could be upper
right or it could be down or left so
after five steps each person could make
two times two times two times two times
two which is equal to two to the five
possible choices so if each person can
make two to the five choices for two
Walker's there will be two to the five
times two to the five which equals four
to the power of five choices so the
total number of paths is four to the
power of five so we can now calculate
the probability by taking the number of
successes which is a number of ways they
can meet divided by the total path this
is going to equal 252 divided by 1024
which is approximately 24.6%
so we figured out the answer for a five
by five grid we can now generalize our
logic to an N by n grid so imagine we
have an n by n grid Alice and Bob
they're only places they could possibly
meet would be after exactly M steps it's
going to be the same logic where they
can only meet along the main diagonal
that's the only time they could be at
the same place at the same time
furthermore we can use the same argument
about the number of ways they could have
paths to reach these points these are
going to be the binomial coefficients so
now let's try and calculate the
probability we again have that for each
of these points there are X ways for
each person to get to that point thus
there are total of x squared ways for
both of them
to get to that point so the number of
ways that they could meet is going to be
the sum of the squared binomial
coefficients furthermore at each step
each person has two choices so after n
steps each person has two to the N
possible choices
so for queue walkers there would then be
2 to the N times 2 to the N which equals
4 to the n choices so before I get to
calculating the probability of dividing
this by the total the ways they can meet
divided by the total path I'm going to
simplify the number of ways they can
meet so in this formula where we have
the sum of the squared binomial
coefficients I'm going to write this in
a different way instead of writing it as
square term I'm going to take one of the
terms in the square and I'm going to
write it as the other equivalent
binomial coefficient this is using the
property that n choose J is equal to n
choose n minus J this goal is directly
from the definition now how can we
evaluate this summation well let's
imagine a problem if you have n women
and men how many different ways are
there to make a group of n people I
claim this sum exactly counts the number
of way the first term would be say that
you choose a group with 0 women and n
men so that's n choose 0 times n choose
n then you need to add it to choosing
one woman and n minus 1 men and then you
keep adding it where you have K women
and n minus K men until you add up all
the different ways that you could have a
certain number of women and a certain
number of men in the group so this
summation counts the number of ways that
we can choose a group of n people when
we have n women and n men but there's
another way that we could evaluate and
solve this problem we could also count
by thinking that there are 2n people
total in this group we want to make a
subgroup of n people therefore there
will be 2n choose and ways to make a
group of n people so we counted the
answer in two different ways and
therefore the number of ways is all
equal to 2n choose n so now we can
calculate the probability based on the
total number of paths which is 4 to the
N we take 2 n choose n divided by 4 to
the power of n but there's another
simplification we can make q n choose n
is known as the central binomial
coefficient this is because it's the
center term of an expansion it has an
asymptotic form of 4 to the power of n
divided by the square root of pi times n
this can be shown using Stirling formula
or also by considering some other
asymptotic form I provided a link where
you can see that now if we use this in
the probability that they meet we look
at the asymptotic probability and the
four over encamped lout so we actually
get the probability to meet is going to
approach 1 divided by the square root of
pi times n and this is absolutely
amazing that Pi comes into this
probability question this leads to an
unusual way that we could approximate pi
we could simulate two random Walker's on
a large n by n grid we could then
estimate the probability that they meet
and get an answer ech the estimate of Pi
will then be 1 divided by the quantity x
squared times n this is a very slowly
converging and bad approximation but
it's interesting to see that pi appears
in this problem did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
maps and game theory you can catch
around my blog mind your decisions which
you can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch your own social
media app for a shell worker and if you
liked the video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description